Why do People Tell Actors to Break a Leg?
The term, of course, means “do well” or
“have a great show” and is typically used
before a stage performance, a show, or an
audition.
(I have never heard it used before filming
a movie on any of the movies I’ve been involved
with, but I guess it can be used in that sense
too).
But I’m sure you’re more interested in
the origin of “break a leg”.
Like many popular sayings and terms, the origin
of “break a leg” is nebulous and disputed.
The term “break a leg” was used originally,
many say, to discourage evil spirits from
deliberately causing one’s performance to
suffer.
According to this theory, wishing someone
“good luck” would be invoking the “evil
eye”.
So “good luck” would actually cause bad
luck for the actor.
Thus, “break a leg”, by this logic, would
be a wish for good luck.
This is in line with the first documented
instance of someone saying “break a leg”
in terms of wishing them luck.
In an October 1, 1921 edition of the New Statesman,
Robert Wilson Lynd is talking about it being
unlucky in horse racing to wish someone luck
so “you should say something insulting such
as, ‘May you break your leg!”
He also mentions that theater people are the
second most superstitious group next to those
involved in horse racing.
Another of the early documented references
of “break a leg”, this time directly referring
to theater, was in the 1939 A Peculiar Treasure
by Edna Ferber, where she implies a different
motive, “…and all the understudies sitting
in the back row politely wishing the various
principals would break a leg”.
Thus, they say it hoping the principal actors
will break their leg so the understudies can
possibly take the lead.
Another possible construction is the German
phrase “Hans un beinbruch”.
The sentiment here is “Happy landings”
in English.
Both English and German pilots use the term,
but the literal translation is “breaking
all one’s bones”.
It is possible actors adopted this phrase,
as it was just after WWI that the “break
a leg” sentiment seems to have gained widespread
popularity.
The term “break a leg” may be traced back
to the Elizabethan language.
To “break a leg”, in Shakespeare’s time,
meant, literally, to bow- by bending at the
knee.
Since a successful actor would “break a
leg” onstage and receive applause, the phrase
would, in effect, be a wish for good luck.
However, in the 16th century “break a leg”
also meant to give birth to an illegitimate
child, which is hard to connect to the theatrical
world.
Others trace “break a leg” to the tradition
of audiences in Ancient Greece.
Instead of applauding actors, audiences would
stomp their feet.
Stomping to the point of actually breaking
a leg is unlikely- but still, the phrase may
be figurative and not literal.
An interesting historical theory attributes
“break a leg” to the assassination of
Abraham Lincoln.
This theory traces the term to the great 19th
century actor, John Wilkes Booth, who, of
course, shot President Lincoln at Ford’s
Theater in 1865.
After Booth shot the President, he jumped
from Lincoln’s upper box seat onto the stage,
where he literally “broke his leg”.
(Some also present this as a possibly origin
of the popular phrase comedians and comics
use for a successful show: “I killed them.”
/ “I killed the audience.”)
Landing a role in show business is called
“getting a break” and being newly successful
is called “breaking into the business”.
These also may be where the “break a leg”
term evolves from.
So as you can see here, the exact origin of
“break a leg” for wishing someone luck
is murky at best.
But whatever first spawned the exact phrase,
it seems plausible enough that it either grew
in popularity from the idea of wishing bad
luck on someone so that they’ll in turn
be given good luck, as the early documented
references of the phrase imply, or in sarcastically
wishing them bad luck so that the understudy
could perhaps take over the role of one of
the principals if the principal actually broke
their leg.